hey youtubers is Charlie so last week on
my Game of Thrones bonus video I saw a
lot of people asking questions about
Robb Stark and did he did he not have a
will
did he name John snow his air in that
it's really open to debate but I think
between the direction the show is moving
in the books there are a lot of clues
just careful for spoilers from
everything on the show that's happened
so far if you're not cut up through
season five and new round of the
giveaway starts now it's a $20 Amazon
gift card all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video the only hard evidence that
Rob ever thought about naming Jon Snow
his heir at least in the books isn't a
Storm of Swords in the timeline right
after Theon Greyjoy's sacs Winterfell
and pretends like pretends to kill bran
and Rickon Rob wants to ride back north
reclaim his territory and get revenge
for the death of his brothers because he
thinks both of his brothers are dead he
thinks it's going to cause some problems
with the line of Stark succession now
Sansa is still alive but if she were to
inherit Winterfell it would go to her
then husband at the time who would be
Tyrion Lannister obviously Robb Stark
started the war because the Lannisters
does not want them to inherit his home
in Arya who he still thinks is alive is
law so he can't really count on that so
it's really muddy
Jon Snow is like the next best option to
succeed him as he's kind of working this
problem out with his mother Catelyn he
suggests that Jon Snow succeed him she
isn't really hot on the idea remember
she still thinks that he is Ned's
bastard so she's always kind of viewed
him in the light that he is not truly
family so he conducts this meeting with
a small number of his close advisers
about retaking the north and what's
going to be happening next like he's
just starts making battle plans in
general there's this really interesting
line that said if you keep all your
treasures in one purse you only make it
easier for those who would rob you so he
basically sends a couple different
people in different directions with
different copies of a letter and so when
people talk about Robb Stark's will they
think that that letter the letter that
was sent out is the will the problem is
is that between the books in the show no
one knows what's inside those letters
George R Martin hasn't revealed it
neither did the show but it stands to
reason that he addresses his succession
in them is like a contingency plan
should he fall in battle the problem is
is that those letters haven't been read
since he died at the red wedding the TV
show has only done a couple of the
characters that were there at the
meeting in the books there's
John umber and galbart Glover in the
books there are more characters there
that are still alive in the books so the
books might take a different route to
finding out what's in those letters
there's a lot of different theories
about the well but if we're talking
about this show we have to subtract a
couple characters now on the TV show
great John number was not present at the
twins during the red wedding so he's
still alive so potentially he could know
what's inside the will and galbart
Glover is still considered alive because
he was only seen in season one briefly
so there are two opportunities right
there for characters to come forward and
say we know Robb Stark names in air in
his will and this is taking on an
assumption that Robb actually did name
John snow his heir I'll I'll explain
that in a second we need to explain how
the show might legitimize this first the
third option is that there might be a
copy of the letter in Old Town because
there was a ship's captain hailing from
Old Town that was also at the meeting so
obviously Samwell going to Old Town so
that's just one option you know Samwell
finding a letter that legitimizes John
Snow he does not know about the Nights
Watch mutiny right now Samwell hasn't
found out about that yet the TV show
seems like it's going to be doing some
more umber related stuff it just seems
like it casts small John umber so there
there are opportunities with the
northern Lords and there's an
opportunity and old town for the show to
say hey there's a copy of the letter
here so now that we've established that
we need to talk about why would it be
important for Robb Stark to name John
snow his heir based on the direction the
show is going if the north is going to
rally behind someone against the
Bolton's and kick them the hell out
there needs to be a legit heir with
stark blood that everybody likes if
someone like John Snow were to come back
and try to secure the loyalty of the
north and in rallying an army together
it'd be a lot harder if he didn't have
any kind of legit claim to Winterfell
that doesn't mean it'd be impossible but
went sure way to secure loyalty beyond a
reasonable doubt would be to hold up an
official letter saying I am the heir of
Winterfell by rights this belongs to me
not these people these Bolton's that you
all hate so why don't you come help me
get rid of them Dan and Dave you know
for all that the changes they made to
the books have been really clear about
the way they explained things on the
show to viewers they want to feed us
enough information that we can follow
the show we kind of know the direction
that it's headed we kind of got the
tease with Stannis offering to
legitimize Jon Snow
speaking in Joseph Campbell hero terms
he refused the call of course don't
worry to come back he would probably
accept the call they just
part of the standard hero's journey hero
gets offered something they refuse they
get offered again they finally accept
you could talk a lot about the way Robb
Stark felt about Jon Snow he definitely
felt like they were brothers he treated
him with the greatest of respect you
know unlike Catelyn Stark who wasn't
super hot on him which was probably one
of her great regrets but remember Ned
Stark convinced her that Jon Snow was
his bastard so you can't blame her too
much but I think as much as Robb Stark
cared about Jon Snow the choice to name
him his successor would have been more
of a practical thing like I don't want
the north to fall into the hands of an
enemy and obviously a lot has happened
since the red wedding and it has fallen
into the hands of the enemy yes Sansa
has married Ramsay giving the Bolton's
rights to Winterfell legitimately so I
think that might be the legal way the TV
show will get around the Bolton's
holding Winterfell and obviously there's
a difference between occupying it
physically with a giant army and legally
holding it it just makes it a lot easier
to get the support of the realm when
someone is illegally holding someone
else's territory and just to be clear
the only people that can legitimize
bastards which is what Robb Stark would
have had to do to name him his heir is
Kings and at the time during the Battle
of five kings Robb Stark was king of the
north
he was also technically the head of the
household so he could do that to the
Lord of the house can also legitimize
his bastard which is why Roose Bolton
was able to legitimize Ramsay snow so
that's just an explanation of what Robb
Stark's letter is and why it might be
will and where it might exist right now
on the TV show let me know in the
comments even if you haven't read the
books do you think that Robb Stark named
John Snow his heir do you think that the
letters that he sent out contain orders
about the succession or if Jon Snow
comes back I mean I feel like we still
have to say that just careful for
spoilers please use spoiler tags you're
going to be commenting about Jon Snow do
you think the show is going to offer a
different solution for a Jon Snow rally
you know Jon Stark Jon Targaryen however
you want to think about it as I've
explained before I do believe the are
plus l equals J theory of jon snow's
parentage but even if that's true Sansa
would still by rights control Winterfell
because she's Ned Stark's oldest living
heir Jon Snow would be her cousin so by
rights he would only get Winterfell if
she were to die unless Robb Stark named
him his heir then he would get to jump
the line
I'm sure you guys have like a billion
awesome question so we can continue this
in my Q&A tomorrow but later tonight is
going to be the fear The Walking Dead
finale so make sure you guys check it
out I'll post my video for that after it
airs ro most of that dunk and egg book
release so I think either by next week
or the week after that that's what the
giveaway is going to be for and there is
a bunch of TV coming back next week so
you can follow me on Twitter and
Facebook for updates on like new shows
that I may be posting videos for most of
you guys probably know what's going on
but they're links for all that in the
description just because there's been so
much talk about people filming behind
the scenes stuff going on on the set of
season 6 you guys can click here to
learn all about the Tower of joy that
doesn't contain you know videos from the
set or anything like that it's just an
explainer for the history the tower joy
and why it's important and you can click
here to learn all about Arthur Dayne in
the books thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you